hello everyone
thank you for joining us today we will
be starting in
another 15 minutes
me
as you are joining in please keep your
microphones uh
muted and your videos turned off
hello everyone thank you for joining us
today we are going to be starting in a
few more minutes
and in today's session uh we will be
talking about the omex logic data
science program
so as you are joining in please keep
your microphones muted the chat box is
open and you can post any of your
questions or queries
in the chat box and our team will be
reaching out to you
and helping you with those queries
and also please keep your videos turned
off
and this uh webinar is also being live
streamed right now on youtube
so if you're comfortable you can also
watch us on our youtube channel which is
by the name find biotech
and hello gaurav how are you doing
if you have any questions please keep
posting them in the chat box
and we will be addressing them
throughout the session
and as we go forward with today's
webinar we will stop for questions
so that we can address as many people as
possible during this
one hour webinar session
oh wonderful girl
so oh god of what are you doing right
now and also others you also can share
more about yourself with us
in the chat what you're doing right now
and why do you think that you want to
study data science
hello
good evening to you too
so where is everybody uh joining us from
today okay gaurav great wonderful
hello zeal hello safa
hello iftikar great to see you here
nice to meet you too it's in
wonderful zeal thank you for sharing
creative sticker we are going to be
addressing
data science today and talking about how
you can
start right at the basics and progress
from there especially in relation to
biomedical data analysis
thank you muskan for sharing
a wonderful itica that is great
so we will be starting in exactly nine
minutes
as the session is scheduled because you
know many people are joining right now
so we would want to wait for everyone to
join and we will start
in nine minutes from now
yes we would be addressing not only just
data science but also
different projects as well in this
session and in the upcoming sessions
next week
thank you sanchita
yes we will be uh also talking about the
basics of biformatics related to medical
biotechnology
thank you shujanika
let us see in this session
what are the different opportunities for
these eras
that all of you are interested in
thank you manal thank you for sharing
about that that's very interesting
we would love to know more about you and
you can
follow us on our several uh groups that
we have on social media
and we also keep sharing and featuring
the participants who have done really
well in our program
so you can find all of that in our
facebook groups
and uh if dr mohit you can also
share about the linkedin group in the
chat that would be great
thank you
so in all of our social media groups we
keep posting about all of the different
opportunities that are available in
these domains that
you all are interested in and have been
mentioning in the chat
and you can join these groups to explore
more
thank you
okay
so we are ready to begin thank you for
joining us today
welcome back to the free webinar on omix
logic data science
in today's session our team will be
sharing
information examples and an overview of
the omixlogic training resources
designed for anyone to learn data
science for biomedical data as seen
in application to projects sourced from
current
topics in biomedical research
over the course of the past several
years
our team has been collaborating with a
number of
academic institutions around the world
that have participated in content
evaluation
curriculum review and project design
as a result the omics logic programs
have been thoroughly evaluated and are
known to lead
to excellent outcomes importantly the
programs are designed to support
students with minimal bioinformatics
background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics data science
and biomedical research the goal of the
omics logic programs
are to provide training in
bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors
and peer example developing a growing
community with
shared passion for data driven research
and appreciation of citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of
all backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using
latest technology like
the program is designed to offer an
introduction to statistical analysis
and machine learning and a broad
overview of
technologies and project examples to
learn about
and develop practical data science
skills
using user-friendly cloud technologies
as well as
r and python coding
omits logic is a program for
bioinformatics training that was
developed
in collaboration between pine biotic and
the tauber bioinformatics
research center what we will discuss
today is a result of
hard work by an amazing team led by
company co-founders dr alfred tober and
dr leonid brodsky
dr alfred tober comes from a medical
background
and has extensive expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation and has been recognized
internationally for his generous support
of
many research projects and initiatives
that support data science training
and applications in medicine dr leonid
brodsky is the director of the
tauber bioinformatics research center at
university of haifa
and an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has numerous publications in
mathematics
and bioinformatics and over the course
of his career
has developed multiple novel algorithmic
approaches to biomedical data analysis
the rest of the team you see here
includes
experts in bioinformatics computer
science and training
some of our team will be presenting
today
so let me introduce you to the mentors
and the speakers of today's session
we have our ceo and co-founder elia
brodsky
in his current role he has extensive
experience
working together with industry and
academic partners
that are applying multi-omics
integration
and bioinformatics to a variety of
biotechnology
and clinical applications julia panoff
is a bioinformatician
and has developed many of the resources
we use for the omics logic programs
dr harpreet kaur is our omits logic
trainer
and expert bioinformatician who will
guide the sessions
and assist participants with projects
and analysis during the program her area
of specialization is cancer genomics and
machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is our omics logic
project mentor
and an expert in big data and
computational biology
to start today's session i would like to
invite elia to speak now
thank you elia and over to you
thank you very much peeps
sorry elia must have um some technical
issue
so he'll be joining in a minute as i see
maybe by that time you can tell them
about the attendance certificate
but people
disconnected let me get back to my
presentation
okay so uh welcome everyone to this
webinar and i'm really excited to be
able to share
with you a couple of things about this
upcoming program now i have to mention
the reason
why we are doing these webinars the
reason we're doing these webinars is
because we
know that there is an increasing
interest
in bioinformatics and in data science
there's a variety of people from
different backgrounds
and so we're hoping that we can explore
how we can adapt the elements that we
have designed and developed for the
omixlogic programs
to assist you at your level now we're
going to introduce to you
some of the topics that we will cover in
the program we will give you
an example from cancer research
presented by dr harpreet kaur
and we'll also talk about some of the
general challenges
as well as opportunities for those of
you that are interested in data science
how to develop skills that are needed
and how to make sure that you understand
the logic of the analysis which is
the main objective of these omixlogic
programs
this is not a workshop where you will
get
hands-on experience and develop skills
the reason for that is because we have
only limited time
and really we are exploring how to best
allow most of you to join
one of the upcoming programs or benefit
from some of the resources that we have
available
online so for those of you that have
joined to receive a certificate
unfortunately this particular webinar
will not come with a certificate it's a
free
informational webinar about an upcoming
program
for those of you that feel that the
content of this
webinar is not informative
that is okay this is intended to
introduce you
to the upcoming program that we will
cover
but we do hope to learn more about you
and to really take away the feedback
from the type of people that join these
programs and
join these webinars to make sure that we
can
be more effective at what we do so again
thank you for joining and i wanted to
start by asking you
a couple of questions both about your
current level education
and if you mention your education
whether you're in high school
you have an undergraduate degree
graduate degree or postgraduate degree
if you would like please share with us
also
what institution do you currently work
for or
study at be it a school a university
or a company we would love to know and
we will save it in our records
so that we know where people are
primarily coming from
now for those of you that are coming
from an international
institution we obviously are encouraging
you
to continue and attend these webinars
but we also have specific programs that
are designed for different time zones
and for different localities so that's
one of the reasons why we are interested
to
understand more where you're coming from
so to answer the questions that we will
have throughout the webinar
we will ask you to just put in a number
so number one would be high school
number two undergraduate degree number
three graduate degree and number four
postgraduate degree
so please put your answer in the chat
excellent thank you very much for
sharing this information now
the reason why we're asking is because
we know from previous programs
that about 75 of all of our participants
have either a masters or a phd
in some area of life sciences
and that is why a lot of the materials
that we have
are focused on that audience
that either has a graduate degree
or a postgraduate position or
they intend to pursue that career path
so you're genuinely interested in
research problems
you understand how data is becoming a
major part of
answering those research questions and
one of those
reasons drives you to pursue
more experience with bioinformatics and
gain more data science skills
so that's why i come to my second
question the second question
is what do you expect from this program
so
thank you for everyone that answered
unfortunately if you did not answer that
is fine we'll actually
guide you to a free course where you can
fill out a
full uh survey about your background
but my second question is about what do
you expect
to gain from joining this upcoming
program so this webinar as i mentioned
is informational but we're really
wondering what might be the outcome that
you are most interested in so here are
the options number one
is to learn about omix data analysis
number two to get familiarized with data
science and data science skills
number three an overview of statistical
and machine learning methods
or number four apply data science to a
research project
okay or 5 all of the above
all right excellent i i think this is
very exciting for me to learn also and
this confirms
what we are striving to do with these
omixlogic programs
we are designing these programs to help
you both learn
and apply these skills to a research
problem so today
we will talk about some of the skills
talk about some of the resources that we
have to help you develop those skills
and then we will also talk about an
example project
that dr harpreet kaur worked in her
research which has to do with
genomics data in cancer and discuss
how similar types of projects you will
be able to develop
during this upcoming program
so first let's talk about bioinformatics
and data science and i know that there
has been a discussion in the online
community about both
similarities and differences between the
two
so as you know bioinformatics itself has
these three components statistics and
maths computer sciences
and biology and so when we speak about
data science
a natural question is why are we now
speaking about data science as something
new and not continuing to just speak
about bioinformatics
and so let me briefly speak about what
is typically expected from
a bioinformatician so a bioinformatician
is not expected to be an expert in
everything
but they should have some practical
experience and that practical experience
is shown in a project but here are some
general skills that one might
expect from a bioinformatician working
in a research lab
they should have domain specific data
processing and
quality control general data
transformation and
filtering applied statistics and machine
learning
applied means that you don't necessarily
understand the theoretical components
but you know how to apply them
efficiently
general data visualization and reporting
tools
as well as very domain specific data
visualization
specific data integration so you know
how to work in an environment
where you might have to use apis
databases and specific types of files
that have been compressed
and being able to write code with
version control for data analysis tasks
the code should be reusable efficient
and documented
and many people in the lab are required
to write python or r packages
for reuse so we will typically
develop a script or develop some kind of
a function
that other people need to be able to use
and finally an important component of
this is being able to communicate data
driven insights or stories
in publications posters and
presentations
including multiple interactions with
people that have
minimal data science or computer science
background
that should still understand the
insights that we're bringing to them
now how is this different from data
science itself data science
includes statistics and maths computer
science and also
some kind of a specialization so really
when we talk about data science
it is much more agnostic of the domain
that it is applied to so according to
such course platforms like udacity
the essential skills of a data
scientists are
programming machine learning statistics
data data visualization
and communication data intuition
and other related skills so really
the components of data science and the
components of bioinformatics
are very much alike however when you
think about
the transferable skills the skills that
you're gaining
out of this course it is important to
think of it
as a building block for your career path
or as a building block in your
research so one of the benefits in
learning data science
apart from bioinformatics is that you
really gain
a wider broader perspective
on how to apply data processing
data wrangling visualization and
analysis skills
to a variety of data sets that come your
way when we speak about bioinformatics
oftentimes bioinformaticians are going
to have
a very specific niche focus that
prevents them
from being able to deal with new
problems effectively and so this
program is going to be able to provide
you with
a broader overview of some general
skills
that will go beyond your typical
bioinformatics training
now some of these skills are going to be
very important also in application
to biomedical research and biological
research
which does fall under the domain of
bioinformatics so you will see
a lot of overlap now what are some of
the data challenges and opportunities
that
are happening in biomedical research as
we speak
over the past 20 years there has been a
phenomenal growth in adoption of high
throughput technologies like next
generation sequencing
which is both more and more affordable
and
widely adopted in biotechnology
where people rely on insights and
regular
generation of data to drive experiments
and validation
as well as in the pharmaceutical
industry and
clinical practice these technologies
produce
an exponential growth of data
that one has to deal with to
get insights about a biological
phenomenon
or about a clinical application
now in parallel to this being driven by
companies
a tremendous amount of data is publicly
accessible
which means that many of us as we
learn about bioinformatics as we learn
about these data types
have access to data sets generated in
professional labs
that all of us can start analyzing
however we're also facing a challenge
and the challenge is that this big data
trend has produced
a big data problem that precludes many
biologists and clinicians from gleaning
knowledge
from these data regarding the nature of
malignant processes
and the relationships between clinical
phenotypes
and their molecular drivers so this
program
will allow you to get some exposure to
the nature of these big data sets
and see how data science skills can help
you address
some of these challenges to make
biological interpretation now what do we
mean
by biological interpretation or
biological
insights that we glean from these raw
data sets so these data sets like
omix technologies for example next
generation sequencing
is a sequencing of dna or rna material
found
inside the cell we can also talk about
phenomics which is
the visual and phenotypic
characterization
of biological samples and here we can
see
phenomics for example could be an image
of
cell lines so when we look at the image
and we can characterize the shape
and the different properties
of these cells we can generate what's
called phenophenotypic
data that phenotypic data is
generated by looking at the outside
of the biological sample but omics data
from the molecular perspective generates
data about what's happening on the
inside for example when we talk about
dna sequencing dna sequencing
generates information about
the differences in the dna of a
particular
sample from a reference genome
and so here you can see an example of a
table of somatic mutations
that produces a characterization of
different types of mutations relevant to
cancer
now over the past several years maybe 20
or so
there has been a growing interest in how
the genomic information gets
translated into functional proteins
and that goes through the process of
epigenetic regulation so this is
information that is not stored in the
dna
but still affects gene expression
finally it has been known that you can
easily study protein composition
by looking at mrna and microrna
expression so we can
capture rna from the cell and we can
study
alternative splicing as well as level of
expression of different genes
so together all of these technologies
provide
a massive amount of information about
what happens both
on the outside and on the inside
of the cell as a result giving us
insight
into how we can understand molecular
drivers
of conditions that might have clinical
and basic mechanistic insights into
the biology now all of these kinds of
data sets
actually help us understand
this data but they first need to be
processed
so when we process this data we are
generating different types of structured
data
from raw sequencing reads and this
this is a major component of
bioinformatics is to understand the
technologies
that generate this kind of data and
build pipelines
that will process this data and turn
them
into structured tables once those data
sets are structured
downstream analysis helps identify
specific types of patterns that
are associated with the different types
of data
that were generated for example we can
talk about
different types of comparison of
conditions and finding
variable patterns we can talk about how
those patterns could be mapped
on the structural properties of
different proteins
and their interaction we can talk about
multivariate analysis of big data that
allows us to summarize
thousands of data points into a visual
interpretation that might have
association with phenotypic data and the
process goes on so
the mastery of these types of processing
and downstream analysis methods pertains
to bioinformatics
specialization in these different types
of omics data sets
now in the clinical or biomedical
applications
these types of methods help us explore
the relationship between clinical
or phenotypic for clinical types of
conditions
data and omix data and the major
objective of such interaction and
finding such association
is to be able to improve the precision
of diagnostic bioassays or
biomarkers and the application of
therapeutics
so design discovery repurposing
and assignment of specific treatment
combinations to patients that have
complex
conditions so a good example for that
might be cancer
where a lot of times we don't have a
clear target
or there's resistance to different types
of treatments
or we need to detect cancer earlier so
we'll talk about an example
in just a few minutes when dr harpreet
starts talking so in the context of
these different challenges
we can look at how to process analyze
visualize and interpret these different
data side
data sets to be able to generate a
portfolio so when you want to tell
somebody
i know data science or i know
bioinformatics the way to explain to
them that
you know bioinformatics or you can apply
data science is to demonstrate
using a project data set so for this
upcoming program
we have prepared a number of curated
data sets
sourced from cutting edge research that
is
peer reviewed and comes from high
quality publications and high quality
labs
so that all of you can gain access to
some of these examples
and try to apply the same methods to
diagnostics and cancer biology
which we'll talk about today but also
single cell and tissue composition
as well as the microbiome and infection
so you'll be able to actually
study these different data sets and see
how these data sets can be
informative in the context of clinical
application
now when we speak about the data science
part of this
process we need to understand how the
whole data science process
works so we need to talk about the
experimental design
and what factors or perhaps biases
it can introduce into the data set
we talk about the process of cleaning
filtering and preparing the data set for
analysis
how to do exploratory data analysis when
we use
visualization and data mining to find
patterns that might be informative and
interesting and oftentimes
that generates a hypothesis
the hypothesis in a clear
data science perspective is different
from what we call
a hypothesis in the biological sense
in the biological sense a hypothesis
is typically about some condition
that has an observable pattern that
could be validated through statistical
analysis
when we talk about a data science
hypothesis
we are talking about designing a model
out of the many potential models that
are out there
you have to understand what a model can
produce
but also what factors need to be
accounted for
in each particular model and so the
design of the model
that includes multiple statistical tests
and that can include machine learning
models that need validation
and that need a certain criteria for
passing the validation
all of that falls into the domain of
data science being able to
translate the data analysis
into a model and then provide
significant information about the
performance of the model
and the different outputs of that model
to communicate
with biologists and clinicians and so a
big part of what we'll do
in this program is try to
highlight some of these aspects and
allow you to try them
on your own so that you understand how
this process works
overall now obviously i mentioned
machine learning and data mining and so
it would be useful to explain exactly
what i mean
by mentioning these terms there has been
an increasing interest in data mining
machine learning classification deep
learning
and artificial intelligence so i think
from the perspective
of a data scientist that works with
biomedical research data
i think the utility of some of these
models is tremendous
in particular it's important to
highlight that previously when we relied
on simple statistical models
oftentimes we were limited by the
ability to deal with
big data sets that contain a lot of
variation
that does not conform to the statistical
assumptions about data which was
generated before we see this emergence
of high throughput data
so there's a lot of heterogeneity
there's a lot of
features for each sample and there are a
lot of challenges
in finding complex associations
between feature to feature and feature
to
the object description or the phenotype
so what we'll do in this program is
we'll take a look
at some of these commonly used basic
machine learning models like decision
trees
or like discriminant analysis and
see how computational methods
that help with feature selection
that help with the robustness of
models that we describe and help us
improve
accuracy and the predictive power of
these different models
has led to an emergence of this field of
data science for machine learning and so
we'll talk about
the different models and the different
use cases for when these models
and the selection of the appropriate
model actually
plays an important role in biomedical
discovery
now it's not only important to know the
statistical principles
and to apply the models in some sense it
has become
easy there are visual interfaces
and simple packages that you can call a
very complex model
with a single line of code but what's
important is as you understand the
variety of methods and different data
types and can match the two
to answer a question or to generate a
hypothesis
you also need to make that model
explainable
you need to communicate the results to
your collaborators that come from the
world of
biology biomedical sciences clinical
sciences
or even the world of business that
includes business of research where
there's funding
and there's a different translational
value to different projects
to explain what you have found in the
data
and why that is significant and so we'll
spend con
considerable time speaking about
methods of visualization that are
intuitive
and informative for
non-bioinformaticians or non-engineers
so to give you an example of how such
projects are taking place today
in the world of cancer biology and
in the world of clinical application of
bioinformatics
i wanted to introduce you to dr harpreet
kaur
she is a trainer with the omixlogic
programs
and she will also share from her
experience during the program when it
starts in october
but today i would like her to introduce
some of her research background
and explain how some of these
methodologies have played a role
in the research that she has done in her
phd
please heartbreak you can take it over
uh heartbreak are you there
she says she's not able to unmute her
thank you
for such a nice session
so my name is harpreet kaur and i have a
phd in bioinformatics
my research is on biomarker discovery
for diagnosis and prognosis of the liver
cancer
so what inspired me to study liver
cancer
is the high mortality rate of this
malignancy
and a lack of precise biomarker that can
help
diagnose liver cancer at an early stage
it is sixth major cancer in terms of the
incidences wide well
worldwide and fourth in terms of
mortality
liver cancer is often times misdiagnosed
or detected too late for an any
effective treatment
another factor that contributes to poor
outcomes
for liver cancer patients is the
frequent reoccurrence of the tumor
so with these concern in mind i have
framed number of research
objectives with my collaborators to
address these
issues using bioinformatics
for the first project of this research
we
use last scale transcriptomics data to
identify
a diagnostic biomarker panel for the
hepatocellular carcinoma
which is a major primary malignancy of
the liver cancer
so in this study we employed 30 datasets
that containing nearly 4000 sample to
lucidity
transcriptomics biomarker panel for the
diagnosis
and the prognosis of liver cancer
implementing
various statistical and bioinformatics
techniques
for the next part of this research
project
we use transcriptomics and methylation
data
to identify biomarker panel for the
stage classification of hepatocellular
carcinoma
here we employ a tcga dataset
of 350 samples and elucidate
51 features that include 30
rna transcripts and 21 methylation cpg
sites
using a number of data mining approaches
the name based model classified early in
the lead stage samples
of hepatocellular carcinoma with with an
accuracy
accuracy nearly 79
for the third part of this research
project
we use transcriptomics data to
scrutinize the diagnostic biomarker
panel
for the chlangiocarcinoma which is
another major
liver cancer malignancy so in
in this study we employed nine data set
that containing 350 colendu carcinoma
133 adjacent non-tumorous and 90
hepatocellular carcinoma sample two
secretinized cleanser carcinoma specific
transcriptomic signatures
implementing a number of machine
learning techniques
like extra tree svm rvf
that is random forest logistic
regression then
lda etc
so in conclusion we identify a universal
platform independent three gene based
biomarker
that can predict hcc patients with high
precision
and also purchase significant prognostic
potential
then we identified a three gene based
clengio carcinoma specific
specific transcriptomic signature
that uh that is capable to discriminate
cca samples from scc and the normal
with uh with an accuracy nearly 90
percent
so at last we identified a biomarker
panel of 51
features that include 30 rna transcripts
and 21 methylation cpg site
to predict the hepatocellular carcinoma
at an early stage
so during this program i am looking
forward to being your mentor
during the this comics logic data
science program
and help all of you learn about data
analysis
machine learning and visualization in
application to the large data set
used in the biomedical research
in this program i will be speaking about
the role of big data
please in biomedical research that can
generate a hypothesis that is then
analyzed
and used for the accuracy improvement
and
how this process is actually affecting
clinical care
now i would like to hand over this
session to dr mohit majumdar
who is the project mentor at pine
biotech so over to you dr mohin
thank you doctor just let me share my
screen
hello everyone my name is mohit mazumdar
and i'm one of the global
representatives of pine biotech
my phd was focused on developing a
noble method to identify and predict the
binding affinity of calcium binding
sites
so as a result i had to master data
mining and become proficient at
predictive
modeling in my current role i am
collaborating and working with academia
and industry to provide support for
bioinformatics education and research
i have 12 years of working experience
and collaborating with pharma healthcare
industry
to solve high priority scientific
questions related to biomedical data
analysis
and bioinformatics capacity building
so as elia mentioned there has been a
remarkable shift
over the last decade in the cost of
generating molecular measurements
so it's just not genomes or dna
sequencing but also
transcriptomes proteomes and metabolomes
so most impacted by this change is the
area of genomic medicine
where it is now possible to move from
generating reference
or population level data to producing
data for
for individuals so we are getting data
from individuals
and concurrently there have been also
advances
in the development of new algorithms and
tools
to integrate and interpret this data
so bioinformatics is playing a key role
in all healthcare industry and
especially in pharma industry
so the pharma industry is now
considering data science and
bioinformatics to be a very important
part of their portfolio
if you see this latest survey you will
find out that ai
and big data have the biggest
impact
however to understand this application
and to be able to find information from
this
big data it is important to learn from
the analysis strategy
that we have been discussing and you saw
the analysis strategy that dr harpreet
showed
and get experience working on real data
sets
that elia talked about so together with
our research collaborators from top
universities we have prepared projects
for you
that takes you through a project based
approach where we take data sets from
high impact publications and use them
for practical exercises
so it is you know kind of difficult to
imagine
what the biomedical industry will look
like in a few years time
but it is certain that this surge in
biological data flow will continue
and this increase in data will be
because of many large
innovative research projects such as the
international human cell
atlas initiative 10 that aims to create
comprehensive reference map
of all human cells and also get data
from devices like
apps variables and implantable
technologies
so in this upcoming data science program
we will learn about
analysis strategies and uh
methods and getting hands-on experience
on real data sets and i'm really
excited to be a part of this data
science program
co-mentoring and working on working with
students and researchers and i'll be
happy to help you
learn the concepts and application of
data science in biology
so with this let me pass it on to
miss deep shady to take this forward
thank you everyone
thank you so much uh dr mohit
so i wanted to take you through some of
the
uh okay let me just share my screen
first
yes through the different program
okay and as you're sharing your screen
uh maybe i can just
answer a couple of questions that are
coming up here in the chat
yeah so uh the questions that you
have could be divided up into two parts
the first part is technical how
can you actually get access to the
program
what type of training will be included
what
is the registration process and all of
these questions will be addressed right
now
by uh beeps as she walks us through the
different resources and the process of
registration
now the other questions are regarding
bioinformatics and data science
so things like how to mine raw data
or maybe where to find the specific data
sets that you can practice with
maybe the differences between different
types of methods
so all of these questions come up
typically
and require some time to address
for example it's not obvious how machine
learning is different from statistical
methods
or maybe different types of machine
learning models
differ in their prediction quality so to
understand
the differences and the technical
components of each one of these
analyses and the different types of data
we'll have to go through a series of
lectures so
when beeps shows the process of
registration she will also
highlight the schedule of the upcoming
programs
and introduce you to a variety of
resources that you'll have access to
in a schedule interactive sessions like
today
as well as asynchronously so you'll have
access to those materials
and you can use them during your own
time on your own schedule
and the two work together to produce the
omics logic program
so i hope that that clarifies it a
little bit and
please go ahead pipsa thank you so much
elia again
so uh first of all let's talk about the
registration process so
here i am putting a link in the chat box
this is the link to register for this
program which is starting
on the 12th of october and it is a
completely one month
program which will discuss about
data science and machine learning for
omics data
so as you scroll down through the page
and you can do that
right with me as i'm speaking you will
see
the different details of this program
and the next thing are the different
session topics
so as you see that in the first session
which is
again on 12th we will be talking about
the introduction to data types and
properties
and on october 14th we'll be talking
about big data challenges and
opportunities
and so on and so forth so we will be
starting at a beginner level and slowly
advancing
so there is a lot of questions that we
get who is this program
for and just to clarify to everyone
and now that we know that all of you are
coming from different
levels this program is suitable
for undergraduate students who are just
starting out
and are interested in learning more
about data science
as well as for faculty and researchers
who are working in this domain
so as you scroll down more you will find
different resources and you will find
some testimonials as well from our
previous participants
an overview of the different courses
and here you will meet our team so
how do you register here you can click
on get started
and you will be given three options to
register
so the basic registration
or the beginner registration will give
you access to
all of the resources that i will be
showing you
in a few minutes but
the intermediate uh
membership will give you access to not
only
the basic resources but also one-on-one
mentor support so if you
have any problem during this entire one
month period
you can actually get on a one-on-one
zoom call with our mentors
and talk to them to solve your issues
so that is what the intermediate
membership is about
and the advanced membership is for
anybody who is doing
a data science project so you want to
not only learn but take it
one step further so you can opt for
this membership because this will allow
you
to go beyond this one month period which
is
till november 4th and do your
data science program and your research
project for
another 30 more days so if you have any
questions regarding this you can always
reach out to me at marketing
at pine.bio for more details
and now once you have registered here
and
you chose any of these memberships that
you would want to go forward with
you will get access to a profile like
this so here i have one profile
from a previous participant and as you
can see that
grace here is from sri lanka
that i can understand because he wrote
about it right here
and what he is doing what he is working
on
you can find right here he has also
added his social media link
so this profile serves as a really nice
way to make a portfolio of yourself
for not only the program participants
but also for anybody else who is a
member of our growing community
they are able to interact and
collaborate and i'll be giving you some
examples in a few more minutes and as
you see
grace has a certificate so as we
mentioned
this particular webinar does not offer
you a certificate but you can definitely
earn a certificate when you join one of
these programs like this
so you see grace as a certificate of
excellence so we got we
give out a certificate of excellence or
a certificate of completion
depending on how you're performing
during a program
and also you can see an independent
project that
he developed along with his
collaborators
so these are some of the opportunities
now let's talk about the resources that
you will have
access to as part of this data science
program
so the first resource you will have
access to
is this forum page or the organization
page
so this page will serve as a classroom
or as one place from where you can
access all of the different
courses materials even the discussions
we have a dedicated forum which i'm
going to be showing you and also here
is mention all of the different sessions
for the upcoming days so you will be
able to see
the timetable as well here and then you
have
a forum so what is the utility of the
forum
the forum offers you the chance
to see any news that is posted
any updates on the sessions to interact
with each other
and to ask questions so say for example
we have a session on the 12th of october
and after the session you had
quite a lot of questions so where do you
ask these questions you post them right
here on the forum by creating a topic
that you can do from right here and once
you create a topic it will be posted
and we will be able to address that in
the upcoming sessions or
also reply back to you right here so
that is what the forum is about
then you have access to a lot of
different courses
so these are only an overview of the few
courses that you have access to but you
have access
as part of this program to a lot more
courses
so you see we have these few courses
which are dedicated machine learning for
biomedical data
and also the pca biomedical data
visualization
in our as well as
projects so these are the asynchronous
materials that elia has been mentioning
besides the live sessions these courses
and these projects will help you learn
more about data science and
explore it on your own at your own time
and space
and moving on regarding the independent
projects as you see
we have a lot of independent projects
that were developed
by our participants our research fellows
and you can find all of them at this
example if you are interested in looking
you can go to each of these videos and
see
what these different participants have
studied and
what they are proposing in their
independent research
so please go through this link if you're
interested we even have high school
students who have been successful
in utilizing the resources and
developing their own independent
projects which they later
presented at science fairs or won some
competitions in
so please take a look at that here is an
example
of a poster presentation
you can also take a look at this
and to keep in touch with everybody
beyond
our own community we have the facebook
and the linkedin group so i had shared
this
links before in the chat so i will be
sharing them again
in linkedin it is called omics logic
machine learning biomedical data mining
and high throughput data analysis
where we post about different
activities different research topics
as well as job news
so that is all from my end elia if you
would like to go ahead and share more
okay thank you very much peepsta and i
wanted to now
address an important topic that comes up
during these sessions
and the question of access
so the question of access is really
about those of you
that have minimal bioinformatics
experience already
that would like to benefit from learning
about bioinformatics and i want to
introduce you to two different
aspects of this problem so the first
problem is how not being an engineer
and not having the capability to code
from scratch
can you get started with analysis of
big data how can you mine publicly
available big data
how can you generate those tables that
you can then visualize
and investigate for patterns and even
how can you develop a sense of the logic
behind the analysis
that we will be discussing in the first
part of this
program so for those of you that are
still with us i would like you to go to
server.tbio.info so this is
the link in this link
you will have a
thank you beeps so on this link you will
see
the areas of analysis so please let me
know
once you are on this site
okay you can just post yes or i'm here
in the chat and i will guide you
on what you can do next so we'll do a
little demo
and you'll be able to try it for
yourself
so please let me know once you're here
okay
we'll wait until at least a few people
are on this
page so we'll wait until five people are
on this link
uh if you could also post the first
demo credential
yeah i have posted both the credentials
so please try it
with um yeah so if you could just use
the first one
beeps i just maybe remove the second one
for now
if you can okay so for those of you that
are on here
i see that maybe three people anyone
else um let's wait a little bit and
maybe we'll get a couple more people to
get to this link
okay so we've got four
so one more one more person once you're
there we'll get started
all right excellent so now you can see
all the way on the side you will see a
login
link so please press on
login and use the first credential
so info at pine dash biotech.com
and the password is one two three edu
test okay please let us know
once you have logged in this is
important if you would like to follow
along
okay thank you beep so the username is
info at pine dash biotech.com
the password is one two three edu test
once you log in you will have access
to a demo that illustrates
how bioinformatics analysis pipelines
are
generated to produce structured
data from raw sequencing reads
so let me give you a demonstration here
on top you see the different areas of
analysis
analysis of next generation sequencing
data mass spectroscopy
structural biology as well as methods
for data integration
analysis and modeling what we'll do
today
is we'll take a look at how to take raw
sequencing read from next generation
sequencing rna-seq
experiments and transform them into
a table of gene expression that will use
them
to visualize using r
okay so first of all you click
on this down arrow
and you can go to the cell line project
demo
so you click on the cell line project
and what you should see
is this pipeline builder okay so for
those of you
that see what i see right here please
put in number one
okay so number one when you start
your bioinformatics pipeline is you need
to be
in the pipeline builder
okay so let's build a pipeline first of
all we need to load the data
but as we load the data you have to go
through a series of steps to process
this data
each job produces a
transformed data set that the next job
will pick up
and pass it on so it's really like a
pipeline that water flows in
and you can generate different types of
output so here we have
the main steps listed which is
pre-processing
mapping and quantification so we'll
first
click on start here you will find
a number of algorithms that are publicly
available
and you can run them on your computer as
well but first before running them you
need to learn
about how they work what type of inputs
and
outputs they produce and what is the
logic of using them
to answer specific biological questions
so let's go to top hat two
top hat two is actually a collection of
different algorithms
that includes multiple steps of data
transformation
and produces a number of different
outputs for example it will produce
a sam file a file that contains
alignment of reads to the reference
genome
so once you produce those reads and you
align them to the reference genome
you can identify junctions
between exons and that gives you a sense
of what kinds of transcripts are present
in your data set once you've identified
the transcripts that information can be
used
to map on the transcriptome or map on
transcripts
and generate a table of expression
that will look like this okay
so once we've generated the table of
expression we can complete our pipeline
and you will get an output so let me
know
how many of you have the output tables
so this should be a gene expression
table okay
now these expression tables
can be now studied using statistical
analysis
but for statistical analysis you need to
have a hypothesis you need to understand
what kinds of groups do we have
in our data what kinds of conditions how
do we compare them to each other
so now please come with me to a
different area
that will also go through in this
program and we'll see
how to use principal component analysis
to be able to
visualize what we have in this table of
expression
okay please go with me to
code.omicslogic.com
you actually have to register here as
well
you cannot use the demo but the
registration
is free so you can register for free and
i'll let you
register as we speak but just to give
you a sense of
what you will have access to throughout
the program
and even if you don't join the program
just if you
have access to these tutorials you will
be able to work with these data sets
and analyze them so here
we start with an introduction how do we
take the table of expression that we
just generated
on the t my info platform which is a
gene count matrix okay and you can
download it right here
and here we apply a method of what's
called
dimensionality reduction so we reduce
the complexity
of this table that has thousands of
genes
and tens of samples
and once we do that we can analyze our
data
for different groups now before we jump
into
how the method works let's see the
coding
part of it so this is a code in r
and you see that it's colors indicate
different
types of syntax the first part
is loading different libraries
so libraries are collections of
functions that have
inputs and outputs just similar to what
we just saw in the pipeline builder
but their objective is to simplify the
process of writing code so you don't
have to write everything
out you just load somebody else's
library and you can
call specific functions from that
library
give it the correct inputs and it will
produce a result
so next we go into the input section
when we input a file
we intake everything that the file
contains
the names of samples the names of genes
and the numeric portion
which is actually what we will analyze
so once we have
a record of what the input file is
we can read that table and specify where
the header is
and importantly separate the labels
from the actual numeric data which is
the matrix
of gene expression now
the methods of analysis that do require
a lot of theoretical understanding
to practically apply them you need to
have minimal knowledge you actually have
to only know
the specific call function how to call
them
and how to pass parameters so here we
have
a call of a function called autoplot
that will sorry the library called
autoplot a function called pr
comp so we'll actually do the
the analysis for us and you can also
extend it
with different types of outputs so let's
see
how this actually works okay so here
you get to the code part of it and if
you have the right data set loaded
which is right here okay you can just
click on run
and it will produce an output right here
in the console
now what we'll do in the context of this
program is we'll try to apply
this same method to a variety of
different data sets
and play around with the different
settings
so that we can improve upon
these basic outputs so for example here
you can see
a 3d plot with the data set
that we analyzed you can also understand
the model
so you can understand how much variance
does each principal component contain so
to really go through all of these
elements
we also have a full course and that
course
explains how this method works with a
lot more
technical detail about every step of the
way
so this is a little overview of some of
the activities
and resources that we will leverage to
make this program
effective interactive and enriching
because we will not only have
interactive sessions where we talk
and present the theoretical background
of different projects
but you also have independent time to go
through some of the materials
on your own
now for those of you that are new to
bioinformatics
i would like to recommend a different
program for you to get started
so before jumping into data science you
might be thinking
this seems very advanced for me i'm not
ready
to spend a lot of time and learn how to
code from scratch and how to
deal with these big data sets so i
recommend our introduction to
bioinformatics for biologists
a program that will simplify a lot of
the things that we'll talk about
and prepare you for next stages
for those of you that are more advanced
and you already feel like you are
ready to not only learn about these
methods
but actually apply them to a long-term
research project and your objective is
to publish
present a poster work on your master's
thesis
or incorporate bioinformatics in your
phd program
we encourage you to explore the research
fellowship
which is an opportunity to learn about
these methods
in the context of your own independent
research project
we meet once a week and discuss
progress on your project supporting you
with assistance from our mentors
interactive community of interns that
are all working on
their projects so you have a way to
collaborate
get feedback from experts and answer any
kind of technical challenges
that you need to overcome
so again thank you for joining today's
webinar
i hope that these resources were
explained clearly
and thank you to bipsa that did an
excellent job
going through the technical details and
the logistics
you'll hear from us again by email we'll
follow up and see if you need any
assistance
with anything that we presented today i
do want to mention that in
all of the resources that we shared
there is
a free level so you don't have to pay
anything
to get started and what i would
recommend
is to get started with our course on
introduction
to bioinformatics so the introduction to
bioinformatics is a course
that provides you with a broad overview
of
the way bioinformatics is used in
medical research basic research
agriculture biotechnology
and the pharmaceutical industry and it's
a great introduction to a lot of these
topics
as well as a survey that you can fill
out to let us know
more about you and help us design
a personalized plan for you to be able
to benefit
from the resources that we have so again
you can register here for free
create your profile become a part of our
community
and start learning for free and these
courses
have certificates that you get upon
completion even the free courses do
and you can explore very affordable ways
to continue and expand your knowledge
as you go through now also on this
platform the coding platform
there are a number of free courses here
as well
and there's a variety of different types
of courses here
including getting started with
bioinformatics on how to process
sequences how to deal with sequence
similarity
how to get started with data science in
r and in python
how to deal with genomic data
metagenomic data
and transcriptomic data and this list
will continue to grow
as you become a part of this program
thank you again and uh thank you mohit
uh
for presenting uh as well as uh
harpreets for presenting about your
research project
uh we'll be looking forward to seeing
all of you
in the program when it starts on october
12th
thank you everyone thank you ilya thank
you